my name is Adrian Ludwig I work at
Google I'm the director for Android
security let me be the 57th person to
welcome you to next thank you all for
coming to what is my hometown of San
Francisco excited to have you all here
we have 59 minutes and 24 seconds to
chat a little bit about Android security
so probably spend about 45 minutes or so
going through content and then hopefully
we'll have some time for questions
towards the end to be able to go through
and would welcome any questions that you
might have and make sure that we get you
the information that you need to to be
making good decisions about what you're
doing in your environment so I'm going
to talk about Android security which is
a big topic we throw around numbers in
the world of Android that sometimes
boggle my mind manohar plus billion
active users is an incredible statistic
and that number grows every day by you
know amounts that you can't really
fathom right
you know the number of people in San
Francisco doesn't begin to approach the
number of new users that we add to
Android as an ecosystem on a daily basis
and so it's really an honor to be able
to talk a little bit about what we've
been doing at Google but also talk a
little bit about how we fit into the
overall ecosystem in terms of protecting
Android users because we're just one big
but still very small part of how it is
that we're approaching protections in
the Android ecosystem and so where do we
really fit in that's that's a good way
to start thinking about Android because
it's very different from other platforms
Google is a Shepherd or steward for an
ecosystem right we're not the provider
of the platform in a strict sense
we're not the maker of all of the
devices that get used by users we're not
the maker of all of the applications
that get used by users and maybe this
part's obvious we're not all of the
users right and so there's a lot of
different parties that are involved in
thinking about how to have security for
an ecosystem of this scale we see our
role as facilitating application
developers by providing them with a
platform that is safe by default that
has api's that allow them to build their
high-security applications or even if
they're not thinking about security to
be able to benefit from the security of
the platform we see users as basically
not wanting to think about security but
having an expectation that security will
be provided and so we've designed the
devices to be secure by default and then
we've built layer upon layer of
protections in addition to that that are
really transparent so that users don't
really need to worry about security and
then on the device maker side we work
very closely with partners large
companies small companies individual
developers to make sure that the devices
that get out into the ecosystem have
security protections and there's a
variety of tools that we have we both
release to open source but then we do
things like build the compatibility test
suite and a compatibility definition
document that can define the security
model across the Android ecosystem so
that we know there's consistency across
the ecosystem and then one of the things
that we've been investing a lot in that
I'll spend a few minutes towards the end
talking about is making sure that
devices are receiving security updates
and optimizing security updates in an
open source environment turns out to be
a pretty interesting and complicated
problem the the security industry and
sort of the software industry spent
about 10 or 15 years figuring out how to
deliver security updates for closed
source platforms and Android has been I
think at the forefront of figuring out
how to do that for open source as well
and so we'll talk a bit about that the
way I tend to think about the problem
because it's so big and because it's so
diverse is to focus in three different
areas the first is on the platform
itself right the code that people think
of as Android and so we'll spend some
time thinking about that then we'll get
into services things that are delivered
as applications most of them by Google
but also by third parties that add
additional security protections and then
the last is what we've done to work with
other parties in the ecosystem to make
sure that friction that can sometimes
impede security doesn't get in the way
of security being delivered and in
particular around
dates and how we're enabling that so my
background for people who are curious is
in creation and delivery of exploits
going back quite a ways and so I was
sort of on the more offensive side of
security and one of the things that was
really interesting from the offensive
side of security is if you look at
security primitives basically 35-ish
years ago the US government put together
something called the orange book and
there are similar types of things that
were put together by other governments
they're been put together in other
places as well but there's a fairly
well-defined set of expected security
primitives that would exist on a secured
device and what's interesting is it's
taken a really long time for the
software industry to evolve to a point
where it's actually providing all those
primitives when I think about Android
and it's sort of phase in that evolution
I put it right next to what I think of
as the other mobile operating system so
Android iOS Chrome OS all uniformly
provide the same primitives which was
the ones that were described almost 35
years ago an orange book and these other
manuals but that just took a really long
time for them to get broadly adopted and
those are isolation of applications
making sure that there was
cryptographically strong device
integrity that was rooted in a hardware
root of trust then there was something
interesting that happened in those
intervening 30 years which was the
realization that there were bugs in
software and so one of the areas that
we've invested very very heavily in is
what we refer to as exploit mitigation
and attack surface minimization which is
technologies designed to make sure that
even if we've made a mistake because let
me tell you we make a lot of mistakes
Google is very good at making mistakes
that's why we have launch and iterate as
one of our philosophies that's why
updates are so important for all of
these platforms but even if there is a
mistake hopefully exploit mitigations
can make exploitation of that in the
real world more challenging over the
last couple of days we've been looking
very closely at a number of
vulnerabilities that we didn't know
about before that became public and
we've been sort of analyzing those and
thinking through how did exploit
mitigations prevent these from actually
being able to be used in the real world
and
what are the technologies that we need
to be continuing to invest in so that
even if there's an issue that we don't
know about we can prevent it from being
a successful exploit and that's an area
that we've invested in a lot management
basically comes down to enterprises and
applications want to know what the state
of a device is and so we've been
investing a lot in making sure that
those api's are available as well when I
look at Android and the other mobile
operating systems for that matter
I see basically complete implementation
of all of the best practices at a
platform level so we're actually in a
really good place across the mobile
operating systems that's very well and
very substantially differentiated from
either server infrastructure or from
other desktop environments so we're in a
pretty good place one of the the
interesting points though about the
mobile operating systems is the velocity
with which new technology can be
delivered and so I want to talk about
one of those new pieces of technology
encryption is a feature that has existed
on Android for I think about six years
it was on devices but it was not enabled
by default users were able to turn it on
enterprises demanded that it be present
it was in the checklist of things that
had to be on a device in order to ploy
it into an enterprise but the reality
was and nobody turned it on that began
to change roughly two years ago with the
Android 6.0 release where the default
configuration on Android devices was to
enable it for devices that were capable
of from a performance standpoint of
having it functioning and not disruptive
to the user experience and so in the
span of about two years we went from
basically nobody having encryption
enabled on Android devices even though
it was available to having over 80% of
new Android devices that are coming out
being cryptid and so that adoption rate
I think is one of the unique
characteristics from a security
standpoint of mobile is if we find some
other technology like encryption that is
really important to defend users you can
expect that it will be adopted very very
quickly and this is turnover rate not in
a sort of slow or not in a highly
managed environment this is for the
overall ecosystem right this is for
hundreds of millions of devices and how
quickly those security features can be
rolled out
and so having this sort of velocity of
security innovation I think is one of
the things that's really attractive
about the mobile platforms at this point
it's also one of the reasons why
investing in innovative security
research is really important because
this sounds trite but we're running out
of areas to invest right we have
encryption we have verified boot we have
good isolation we have good sandboxing
we're basically getting to a point where
we have hardware root of trust where
what is really important is the flaws in
the bugs and so this is an area that
Google and in particular chrome we're
very very innovative about four or five
years ago and saying we're gonna deploy
bug bounties and Android at this point
is one of the largest bounty programs in
the world one of the unique
characteristics of the Android bounty
program is the amount of investment
we're seeing in terms of researchers in
areas of the world that historically
have not been prominent in security
research I'm hinting at China
specifically where we're seeing a
significant number of the researchers
that are looking at Android and finding
vulnerabilities on Android are based in
China so we've tapped into security
research and security innovation that
really is not visible to any of the
other platform providers which is pretty
interesting I have no doubt that
worldwide there are people looking for
the bugs but only on Android are they
actually then reporting them into the
vendor and allowing us to make the
platform more secure so those are some
of the things that we're doing at the
platform level I want to spend a few
minutes talking as well about the
changes and sort of work that we've done
on services and to provide a little bit
of context services historically have
been something that is left to a third
party right if you look at the desktop
platforms for example Microsoft Apple
and the other desktop platform providers
said let's create an ecosystem of
third-party vendors Symantec McAfee
Kaspersky etc etc right dozens if not
hundreds of those security research and
and antivirus and security providers and
that was a model that worked relatively
well but it had significant gaps in
terms of the coverage that those
solutions were able to provide and in
terms of the ability for those solutions
to influence the the direction of the
platform and also respond to knowledge
that the platform provider had so about
five to six years ago when we were
looking at Android we said you know what
rather than having that capability be
highly external to the platform provided
by third parties let's make sure that we
provide a Best of Breed set of security
services integrated with the
applications that we're putting on to
these devices and so Google Play and
Google Play services incorporated a
suite of security services and made it
available for all devices that have the
Google applications on them
that's a very different model than what
we've seen on other platforms in the
mobile space where instead those other
platforms have said security services
are basically forboden or are very
significantly impeded they're not
provided by the platform provider and in
fact it's very difficult to implement on
those other platforms and so the Android
has taken a very different direction
there and it's one that I think over
time is going to be really really
important so when I talk about security
services and have given you sort of that
framing here are the types of services
that we're providing right now out of
the box on any device that has Google
Play on it the first one is what we call
verify apps security is not an area
where we've had a ton of marketing
investment so these are not super sexy
names we need to add some like X's and
Y's and things to make these more
exciting but verify apps does exactly
what you would expect it verifies the
apps that are being installed onto the
device in addition to checking the
certificate that's used to sign the
application verify apps checks with
Google at the intime of installation to
see whether this is an application that
exposes the user to heightened risk is
it I'll use the sort of desktop
nomenclature is it a virus it turns out
on Android we don't have viruses for
various reasons inclusive of the fact
that apps are signed and so the viral
mutation that is at the heart of why we
call things viruses doesn't apply but is
it a piece of malware or is it something
that could be a potentially harmful
application and so every Android
that has the Google applications on it
does these real-time checks at the time
of installation and then again in the
background on ongoing basis we check all
of the applications on the device to see
whether or not it could be a potentially
harmful application that has incredible
consequences which I'll talk about in
just a second in terms of how clean
we've been able to keep the ecosystem
another thing that we have on Android
devices is what we call the sensor
network sensor network is exactly what
you would expect it's a network of
sensors on these devices that checks for
non application based security risks so
beyond verifying the apps we also are
looking at is this device connecting to
a network that's potentially hostile are
we seeing attempted exploitation of
media file formats on these devices and
I'll talk a little bit about what the
consequences of that is so we've got
that across a large number of devices
developer API is I think are probably
one of the things that are even more
interesting for for you folks which is
taking the information from verify apps
and the sensor network and exposing that
so that you can incorporate the
intelligence that Google is generating
about what's going on in the ecosystem
into your own security model and into
how you're thinking about those devices
and those applications right so you can
you can basically say I don't want to
have my app or work if there's ever been
a piece of malware on this device and
Google is gonna provide the services for
you to be able to do that and the last
service that we have there is finding
your lost device right or being able to
respond in the event that a device is
lost or stolen the net of these services
is incredible visibility into the
ecosystem and to give you a flavor for
it we've got over a billion and a half
devices that are protected right now
with these services they're checking in
on a very regular basis right so on
average it's about once every other day
where we're doing about 750 million
scans of the ecosystem you know
individual devices around around the
ecosystem on a on a daily basis and the
number of applications that we're
looking at is also incredibly large ring
because that's one of the largest
concerns that exists in the ecosystem is
what are the applications that are there
the result of that is that we're able to
manage the level of risk in the eCos
them quite effectively this is a graph
going back to 2014 so almost three years
at this point showing the rate of
devices having what we classifies a
potentially harmful application
installed on their on a device this is a
malware rate to put it put it quite
bluntly for the world right and I want
to call that out most malware rates that
exist are from highly managed
environments if you're in an enterprise
you might be looking at you know what's
the frequency with which a piece of
malware gets on to my Mac fleet or gets
on to my iPhone fleet or gets on to my
my Windows fleet for the desktop
platforms those numbers often are on the
order of 10 percent or so right a
managed environment with users who are
you know have active antivirus running
on their device on their you know
desktop platform they might even have
white listing there might be other sort
of characteristics and security defenses
that are in place on those devices but
they still have a malware rate that's
roughly an order of magnitude higher
than what we've seen on unmanaged
Android devices worldwide right so very
different statistic and we see sort of
roughly an order of magnitude cleaner in
fact if you look at something that's a
little bit more similar to what your
enterprise fleet might look like it
would be this second number which is for
Android devices that are only installing
applications from Google Play what do we
see as their malware rate and here it's
actually about you know one twentieth of
the rate that you see for the average
across the ecosystem right it's 0.05 so
a full order of magnitude cleaner and
that's like the basic most simple
management that you can do this is just
say only allow installation of apps from
Google Play if you take additional steps
that are provided through MMS like
whitelisting or filtering the
applications you could you could imagine
that you could cut this down even more
substantially so we're in an incredibly
clean place for the overall ecosystem
which is great if you're doing you know
b2c or delivering applications directly
to consumers and if you're talking about
managing within your own fleet you're
you're able to get much much cleaner
than that as well these scans also give
us visibility into exploitation of
issues that are found out in the wild
right we have a sensor network that's
been delivered out to over 1.4 billion
devices and we're able to look back both
in real time but also historically to
understand the level of risk that
devices might be exposed to this is a
chart these are the three
vulnerabilities that have received
probably the most attention on Android
over the last four years they were sort
of the marquee Android vulnerability at
the 2013 14 and 15 blackhat conferences
held in Las Vegas and sort of the middle
of the summer so master key fake ID and
stage fright sort of in order to of
these our vulnerabilities are
specifically affected the verification
of signatures at the time of
installation and so we have perfect
visibility for devices that have verify
apps and safety net turned on into the
level of exploitation because we
actually checked every single install
that happens on those devices to verify
apps so we can go back and we can with
confidence say there was zero
exploitation before those issues became
public and that even after they became
public the level of exploitation that
took place was extraordinarily low and
then you can contrast that to the level
of communication that existed in the
media right often what I like to do is
look at our data and say you know did
more people read about how scary this
thing was relative to the number of
people who are affected and almost
uniformly that's going to be the case
there are a lot more people that are
frightened by these things than are
actually affected by them which puts us
in a pretty good place stage fright was
a watershed I think for the Android
ecosystem at large in terms of the
effect that it had it ended up driving
much more rapid adoption of security
bulletins and security patches in the
ecosystem we'll talk more about that in
just a second but what's interesting
about it is here we are going on a year
and a half after that issue became
public and there still are no confirmed
instances of any exploitation one of the
things that was really fascinating over
the last
couple of days is taking a look at you
know a new trove of security
vulnerabilities and realizing that none
of them affected media server
none of them referred to stage
frightened right so despite the level of
attention that was focused on that
particular issue it doesn't seem to have
had an actual effect in terms of user
security that's out there again not you
know claiming that didn't blame we
haven't seen it which is I think pretty
interesting that the distance between
what's happening in the ecosystem and
the level of communication around risk
that exists in ecosystem so if you're
interested in the services and getting a
deeper dive into how those services work
Edward Cunningham who's the product
manager for those services is going to
talk tomorrow he's going to go into how
we're using machine learning to detect
specific types of attacks that might be
taking place against users some of the
work that we've been doing with neural
networks and detecting those and talk
through a number of areas of investment
that we're making so I think that is
actually one of the the most interesting
things that's going on is those
advancements and services the other area
that I want to talk a bit about is
ecosystem updates and there's two
different areas that were investing in
you know Google obviously has an
obligation to build the most secure
version of the platform that we possibly
can and to get that out to as many
people as we possibly can but there are
two other parties that have an impact on
the security of a device
the first is application developers and
let me talk a little bit about my again
my experience as someone who came from
the world of application developers
prior to being at Google I was working
on security for desktop applications
headed up security at Adobe and what was
interesting to me and the windows
ecosystem is for the first handful of
years all of the focus on security was
at the operating system level and then
circa 2004 to 2005 there was a
transition where exploitation shifted
from the platform itself into the key
applications and what were those key
applications well Adobe PDF
and reader Adobe Flash or two of
them.the browsers were another one
Firefox ie and Chrome wasn't there at
the time but you know quickly became one
of the areas that was a focal point and
it is still today we also begin to see a
lot of exploitation that was targeted at
other document formats and so what was
interesting was no matter how hard we
had made the platform looking at Windows
there was this shift in where the weak
spot was and so on the Android side we
wanted to make sure that that shift
doesn't take place and so we're very
proactively beginning to look at
application developers and make sure
that they're in a much better place by
default since most applications on
Android are written in Java which is a
type safe language and a memory safe
language by default they're already in a
better place but we wanted to see if we
could do more than that so the approach
that we took was beginning to use the
scanning services that we had built to
find malware and repurposing that and so
the repurposing that we did was to look
for basic vulnerabilities in
applications this is a picture of the
set of new technologies that we
introduced where we were looking for
vulnerabilities over the last year they
range from things like Lib PNP in Apache
Cordova where what we were looking for
was an old version of a library that had
a known vulnerability we scan all the
applications that are in Google Play and
then we notify those developers hey
you're running an old version of this in
many instances the developers like hey
thanks I didn't even know that and they
immediately fix it in some instances the
developers like clueless hasn't been
doing anything isn't paying any
attention and the app continues to exist
the next time that they go to update
their application add a new feature ship
a new release get new users they're told
you can't do that until that of
application has had the vulnerability
that we identified fixed and so this has
ended up having a very significant sort
of what I think of as raising the base
level of security that exists in the app
locations so the simplest one is
something like checking for a vulnerable
version of a library there are more
sophisticated ones as well like the SSL
error handler where what we were looking
for is whether an application is
handling SSL errors in a way that's safe
right
if you check to see you know you've been
able SSL on a particular network
connection you get back an SSL error if
what you say is that's okay just connect
that's probably not what was intended or
you wouldn't have turned on SSL at all
but it's also a very common thing that a
developer will do in a testing phase for
an application right they'll say yeah I
don't really have a current certificate
on my test server and so I'm just going
to allow the connection to go through
and so what we've done here is we've
looked for those types of instances
where the default handler is one that's
allowing all connections we flag the
application we tell the developer look
this is the problem and then they have
the option of either you know disabling
SSL if that's what was their intention
or fixing it so that the SSL error
handler is actually a sane as the sell
error handler so there's a variety of
different levels of sophistication on
the types of warnings that were able to
give to developers I mentioned that in
some instances we're using sort of more
strong enforcement mechanisms through
Google Play to try to make sure that
these devices are that these
applications are being brought up to
date and so that's had a pretty
significant impact this is a graph of
the number of applications that have
been fixed as a result of us delivering
warnings to them right so in 2016
almost 300,000 unique applications that
had their security improve right so
incredible scale in terms of being able
to deliver security protections at the
application level so application
developers are one area focus for us
another is around devices and the
devices that are being built using
Android software right as you may know
expect many people do but there probably
are a few that don't Google doesn't ship
software on devices with the exception
of the pixel and the Nexus devices so
roughly 1% of the Android ecosystem is
binaries that was with consists of
devices that have binaries that were
built by Google the other 99% an OEM
takes source code from an open source
project compiles that and then delivers
that as the software on top of those
devices they go through certification
and CVD and a variety of other
compatibility requirements in order to
be able to make sure that the devices
work well with the rest of the Android
ecosystem but ultimately it's the device
maker that is responsible for delivering
the software under those devices and so
one of the great challenges is how do we
make sure that the devices that are out
there have the most recent version of
the software and that any changes that
might have been made by the OEM don't
negatively affect security on those
devices and so we work really closely
with device makers to make sure that
they're doing that one of the other
things that we work with our carriers so
this is a picture to give you a rough
sense for how many carriers there are
worldwide that we're working with on an
active basis so there are probably a few
more than this this is a screen you know
a snapshot taken not too long ago but
they're out 351 different carriers that
are out there in the world carriers you
know in the United States we're talking
about 18 T Verizon t-mobile Sprint and a
number of other ones as well
carriers play a very significant role
because often they are the source of
purchase for a device where you go into
a carrier store you buy a device they
also have requirements about the
functionality that exists on those
device so they're very strongly involved
in the delivery of software on those
devices right they require applications
that might be installed
they require configuration to work on
their network in some instances the
network protocols are different right
CDMA versus GSM although that's tending
to break down at this point it was one
of the variations that would exist
within the u.s. networks and so we're
working with these carriers to define
what software is going to be on these
devices and what the requirements are
for it now historically cell phones did
not get updated basically at all and
there was a very strong resistance to
updating software on those devices
because of stability at the network
level and so the carriers for many years
had been defining a testing regime
around software for these devices that
was designed correctly I would argue to
minimize the rate at which device
updates could be delivered to those
devices right they didn't want devices
to be changing because change created
instability both at a network level but
also at an individual user level right
if the software change that was bad
there are other factors as well around
congestion and consumption of bandwidth
and so in the Android environment we
were dealing with a software stack
that's much more complex we're dealing
with vulnerabilities that are being
found we talked about stage fright and
master key and a few of the other ones
earlier and so there was a bit of a
cognitive dissonance between the
approach the carrier's had adopted of
minimizing the rate at which the updates
could be delivered maximizing the amount
of testing that could be done and the
need to deliver security updates in a
timely fashion so over the last year or
so but going back further than that but
for sure over the last year so we've
been working a lot with the carriers to
differentiate between updates to devices
that were non security specific versus
ones that were security specific and so
beginning of 2016 roughly the average
update to a Android device at a minimum
from the point where an OEM said I'm
done with this update I'm ready to ship
it out to customers until it had gone
through carrier testing and approval was
on the order of six to nine weeks what
was also interesting about that as
usually that had to be scheduled another
six to nine weeks ahead of time so we're
really talking about an 18 week period
basically from when the OEM is done to
win an update could make it into the
hands of a consumer right so very
difficult to deliver security updates in
a timely fashion over the last year and
a half we've worked with the carriers
basically with all the major carriers
about 40 or 50 of them worldwide to make
sure that if a update was a security
only update then that could be delivered
in less than a week so they've gone
through and said ok if issues are in
security bulletins and if we're provided
with a software from Google then we're
going to be willing to let those go
through at a much faster approval
process and so we've taken advantage of
that to make sure that we're able to
deliver security updates very quickly to
devices so
we've sort of eliminated some of the the
cost associated with it but we haven't
eliminated a lot of all of it so the
next thing that we've been investing in
over the last year or so is in working
with specific OEMs to try to refine what
their development process looks like and
so I want to give you a little bit of a
flavor for what the where we've been
focusing on our effort so beginning of
last year 2016 we sat down and we said
okay we're trying to change an ecosystem
that has over 60,000 unique devices in
it to get it to a point where it's able
to deliver security updates in a timely
fashion how are we going to approach
that so we chopped off the top OEMs and
the flagship devices for those top OEMs
and we said we're gonna focus initially
on updating just those devices right the
ones that you might be familiar with
because you've seen them like on a
billboard or you know they cost six
hundred dollars and they're receiving a
lot those are the ones that we think you
know is the best opportunity to work
with OEMs to refactor their approach so
we talked to the top five OEMs we said
let's look at just your flagship devices
because remember a lot of these OEMs
produce literally dozens or not hundreds
and so it ended up being about 29 device
models across those five OEMs the
flagship in North America might be
different from the flagship in Europe
might be different from the flagship in
Asia so there's a little bit of
complexity there that may not be obvious
as a consumer I like to anchor this and
say at this point you're already talking
about more device models than any other
platform right
you've already like we're not talking
about the full range we're not even
talking about a tiny fraction of the
Android ecosystem but just looking at
these you're already talking about more
complexity than any other ecosystem that
exists in the world
now I mentioned carriers and the fact
that carriers like to have customization
for devices and so those 29 different
device models when you sort of blow them
up across all the different carriers and
the customizations what you end up with
is just looking at the flagship models
for the top five OEMs 5,000 unique
builds of Android that are currently
being serviced that our flagship devices
okay it's 5,000 different development
teams out there in the world
like think about that it's 5,000 git
repositories it's 5,000 QA teams it's I
don't know probably 10,000 different VPS
of engineering all of whom need to be
working in synchronicity in order to be
able to deliver updates on these devices
and so what started as a really simple
hey let's just update devices on a
monthly basis turned out to be a little
bit more complicated than that
and so we've been working very steadily
with those top five OEMs and others in
the ecosystem as well but for the
purposes of this we'll focus on those
top five to make sure that these 5,000
devices are being brought up to date the
sort of output right because who cares
about the process what you really care
about is the output the output is the
beginning of 2016 about some more on the
order of I say less than 20% I think
it's on the order of 12 to 13 percent of
devices were up to date in the last 60
days so basically the last Security
Bulletin that was available was on those
devices that's just for flagships the
number was even lower for the broader
ecosystem by the end of 2016 we brought
that number up to over 50% so on the
flagship devices there was a very
significant change over 50% of devices
in turn up today that's not we're not
done I just want to make sure I'm
expressed about that like this is great
progress right 22:50 huge right the line
is going up to the right but you know
there's you know another 45 ish percent
that we need to figure out how to get
those patched as well and then again
this is just for flagship devices if
you're looking in your environment you
can hone in a little bit on specific
characteristics that may make your
environment safer flagship devices that
were brought in through top carriers in
North America or in Europe have an even
higher patch rate over 70% this does
mean by the way that if you bought your
device not from one of those carriers
then you're necessarily gonna have a
percentage that must be below 50%
because they average out right so you
want to think a little bit about where
you're sourcing devices from and using
them in your environment you also have
the ability to be more select
tip about which devices you want to
purchase if you're in an environment
where you're thinking about how to
source them one device that we recommend
from Google is the pixel we consistently
have an update rate of over 90% patches
are made immediately available I can get
you details about other manufacturers
that also provided as well they're a
little bit more sensitive about us
talking about the devices that they're
making and their update rates but we can
get you more information about that if
you have questions just feel free to
reach out to me and I can help get you
in contact with somebody I can get you
that information there's a really simple
way if you want to have an update rate
that's you know of really simple good
one we provide an API which is build
version security patch level if you're
an EMM you can write a policy that says
I only want to be running on devices
that are up to date you can say 90 days
60 days I would recommend 90 days simply
because there are a number of devices
that basically because your update cycle
is on a 30 day cycle roughly and so if
if devices are more than a couple of
weeks out of date
they'll very quickly a they'll almost
every month end up around 30 days and
then be it's not uncommon that they'll
end up going past 60 and so giving your
you know giving your users the
opportunity to actually apply the patch
get it up to date is the report received
that we would recommend and so we
generally say 90 days is probably the
right approach and so that gives you a
sense for the progress that we've made
before we close on that I do want to say
I think over the next two years or so
we'll begin we'll continue to see an
increase in broad-based adoption of
security updates around the Android
ecosystem that's my sort of forecast is
that it's going to take about two to
three years before we get to a point
where you have you know 80% of all
devices that are up-to-date that it's
taking time for the OEMs to ingest and
modify their processes to be able to
deliver updates on a more regular basis
but that you know all that all the
trajectory is in the right direction
the last thing that I want to mention
is if data is your thing and you want to
know a little bit more about Android
security and in the work that we've been
doing there every year for the last
three years we've produced a annual
security urine review it's about an 80
page document this year it'll be coming
out in the next couple of weeks and I
would encourage you to take a look at it
it breaks down all the malware data at
break down update rates breaks down a
lot of the features and investments that
we've been making in that space so you
can really understand what's going on
across the ecosystem at large and the
last thing that I want to sort of note
is I think often in the security space
we focus so much on the technology
that's sort of at the platform level or
at the operating system level that we
lose sight of the fact that especially
in the mobile space we've really already
begun to unlock business models that
were not possible previously and we've
done that from a security standpoint as
well this one cracks me up a little bit
this is a picture of people playing
pokemons go in in Japan there are
similar pictures from around San
Francisco I just couldn't couldn't find
one they had quite as many heads packed
into a little space all staring at their
screens and gaming in particular on
mobile devices has been an incredible
driver of security I think the security
community often will sort of poopoo it
as it's just DRM or oh it's just games
but this is a billion-dollar business
that depends upon the hardest threat
model which is that the person who has
the device in their hand is trying to
break it and so the fact that they're
able to build this business depends on
two things one it depends on the core
security properties of the platform and
then two it depends upon the fact that
they as developers realized that they
needed to use some of the more
sophisticated features that were
available as services right so they were
one of the early adopters of something
called safety net test ation where
Google tries to assess whether this is a
device that's currently operating in a
good state or not pass that information
up to the application developer so I
think what's interesting is like you
know they've been up they managed to do
that and build that billion-dollar
business I don't have any expectation
maybe some of you are building you know
you're in
our business on mobile maybe you're not
but if you are you know there are other
people that are doing that as well and
they're scaling to billions of dollars
even in a very high-risk environment and
that's something that I want to flag
right is I think often especially in
security there's this reversion to
change a version that makes it
impossible for people to see a oh my
gosh I couldn't do this on Windows
because there was so much piracy and
there was so much flexibility but on
mobile it's actually not just possible
it's happening and games are one of the
primary drivers of it similarly a
payment infrastructure is something that
we've seen very rapid adoption of based
on the security properties of the
platform you know the fact that we're
able to go into major payment operators
and say you know trust the platform
here's capabilities of it is really
incredible and it's something that you
know these folks depend upon trusts own
they depend upon Hardware security in a
way that others haven't been able to and
I think that's one of the reasons why
when you look at you know the most
targeted highest risk users in the world
more and more we're seeing an
acknowledgement that mobile devices are
necessary for them to communicate and
investments that are being made are
sufficient for them to be able to use
these platforms so it's really exciting
time for me to know that you know people
who are the most at risk whether that be
you know world leaders or whether that
be dissidents who are being targeted
they can rely on the technology they
have in a way that never was possible
before from a security standpoint so
that's that's pretty exciting for me so
this was sort of the think about how is
relevant in your environment as well and
how to take advantage of it
you